we have four very different kinds of
talk that kind of I think the first
three talks are somewhat related the
fourth talk is a little bit disjointed
it kind of is more focused on a
particular application that one would
see in a real social media network so
let me try to see if I can do a good job
of connecting detox oh there is a common
theme behind all the four talks and that
is can we rethink how algorithmic
analysis should be done given the new
data models and given the new computing
paradigms like mapreduce online
computation evolving graphs you know
these are very different than what is
generally used to analyze algorithm in a
classical setting and most of them all
three all for talks kind of have a
common theme which is there is often a
gap between what theoretically optimal
solution is for a particular problem and
what are actually used in practice given
the classical assumptions do not hold
right and so the question is can we
bridge this gap and if so how right and
one way is to come up with new tools to
analyze the complexity of algorithms and
kind of move away from the classical way
we analyze algorithm the other is can we
come up with new implementation of
algorithms in these new paradigms and in
more in all in all talks the results are
more illustrative rather than kind of
more conclusive and again all talks as
you could suspect use page rank heavily
to illustrate the ideas but the
fundamental question which we may want
to ask ourself at the end of the session
is can we take these concepts and
generalize it to other problems right so
first talk is going to be by ashish and
again he talks about analyze and
analysis and implementation of some
common algorithms
and why it requires new thinking for
modern data model in particular he
focuses more on the MapReduce model as
well as what is called the actively HD
model which is kind of like continuously
doing MapReduce but the reducers can
actually talk to each other he talks
about simple strategies of how you could
scale algorithms like cosine similarity
and sub graph computation in a MapReduce
paradigm he talks about how one could do
personalized PageRank calculation and
various other nearest-neighbor
calculation in the active DHT modeling
framework so very nice combination of
techniques and illustration and I think
you should you give rise to a lot of new
thoughts i believe and then david is
going to talk about primarily algorithms
that solve prob that that involved
normalized laplacian a random walk kind
of matrix computation on graph and again
he also focuses heavily on page rank
community direction and link prediction
kind of problems and again david is more
focused on asking the following question
can we bridge the gap between practical
algorithm and those that are
theoretically optimum so for instance in
the case of random walk in the case of
random in the case of random walk
algorithm it's known theoretically that
mcmc algorithms are theoretically
optimal there are cases where linear
algebra algorithms are also
theoretically optimum but these are
generally not used in practice so are
their algorithms that we can come up why
why is why are these algorithm not used
in practice and can we come up with
algorithm that can bridge this gap are
there actually applications real-life
applications which are using those kind
of algorithm like mcmc kind of algorithm
and you know part of this is also
discussed in our she says talk like he
also talks about random walk algorithms
and how you can scale it up on a hadoop
crime and DHT kind of environment so
again related Ravi again investigates
the PageRank algorithm primarily under a
very different assumption and the
assumption is what if you have a graph
with changes over time but she
slowly and you are only allowed to probe
the graph a small number of times a
certain fixed number of times right how
would you kind of do computation in this
paradigm and again the question you can
ask after the talk is can the technique
that Robbie is going to talk about in
this region realized can be generalized
to other talks and is this paradigm
where the graphs are assume to change
slowly is it more applicable to other
problems or not right so that is again
another interesting thing and finally
I'm going to wrap up the session so
again as I said this is my my talk is
going to be more rooted to some applied
problem and particular I'm going to talk
about recommender problems but those
that pertain to the graph itself and you
know for for instance if you look at any
social network Twitter Facebook LinkedIn
they have numerous recommended problems
but the graph structure of the whole
network plays a fundamental role in how
these recommender problems are solved
right and so I will talk about what are
the underlying challenges for a commonly
encountered problem by social media
company mainly the feed recommendation
problem so i'm going to use feed
recommendation for illustration but I
most of the challenges would apply to
other social recommender problem as well
and then I'm going to go deeper into a
particular problem which is that of
estimating reputation scores in a
unbiased manner when you have some
feedback on a social network again I'll
come back to that later when so this is
it and it looks very exciting you know
so let Ashish start the session